there's a little trick that you do you
zip it all the way up on the word
beautiful
I noticed that let's make the most of
this come on sweater she used to make
them all oh really yes in fact at
Christmas time she would give a sweater
to each one of us that was sort of an
extended family and there were 12 of us
and she would make a sweater every month
and then at Christmastime give all 12 of
us and then she'd say what kind do you
all want next year said oh I know the
kind you want Freddie you want the one
with the zipper say choose what you like
see people were not allowed to try on my
crown they weren't no you mean the Miss
America had to be just Miss America now
there's a little trick that you do you
zip it all the way up on the word
beautiful why why do you because of
microphones right there ha
so now after the sweater always
twenty-five years you do your shoes is
this the same pair of shoes that you've
had no okay no we've gone through
several pairs my neighbor I have this
never seen for eight years but the first
programs that we did I did the puppets
and the music behind the set it is with
great pleasure that I welcome you to the
castle and the neighborhood of
make-believe entertainment tonight so I
started wearing these things so that I
could write run from one end of the
studio to the other from the organ to
the puppets - and that's why I wore
something and it just stuck huh now what
about coming through the door and and
singing the song and changing every time
II was there what originated the sweater
and the shoes I mean the shoes because
of the running boat
why on the show why was there that that
ceremony kind of thing my show I think
it's a good word for ceremony yeah I
hadn't thought of it as that but again
you know you have a real feel for what
we do and it is a ceremony in fact
tradition is something that makes people
feel very comfortable they know what to
expect and they know that when I come in
there that I'm going to do certain
things to get into comfortable clothes
and we're going to have some time
together then when I leave I get back in
my street clothes and how do we go but
children need to have some
Hank's to feel count and in this world
there are so few of them won't you be my
neighbor
welcome to this neighborhood neighbor
you know I'm not an actor I just give
myself I think the greatest thing that
we can give a child is another honest
adult in that child's life you always
make each day such a special day
you know how by just your being yourself
there's only one person in this whole
world like you and people can like you
exactly as you are
I'll be thinking about you mm-hmm
bye-bye
[Music]